we will start to flinch at stuff yeah
we'll start to flinch at oh you know I
this is how I want my life to be but in
order to get it that way I need to get
rid of this one thing and all that one
thing I paid a hundred bucks for and
maybe I could get 20 bucks out of it
those those little barriers those little
hurdles um jump over them as quick as
possible yeah if that means just
donating your stuff like I promised you
Christine it could be way more worth it
to you than just to just get rid of it
than it is to sit here and worry about
every little nickel and dime that you
can make office because the the price
tag or the money involved is only one
component of a much bigger recipe and I
love what you just said about having a
vision because that vision is going to
keep you on track it's sort of the
horizon or the destination the direction
is probably the better way to put it
your vision is the direction in which
you want to travel now you'll get where
your house is closer to your vision and
the vision might shift a little bit it
might pivot slightly or my pivot
significantly once you start letting go
of some of these things and you're like
wow I can let go of more this is this is
freeing I feel lighter my house is way
easier to clean once you start getting
rid of these things and you get that
that momentum and that momentum carries
you forward letting go builds the muscle
of letting go even more
you